ça va
on
sac
[Musique]
je
voilà monsieur le premier adjoint qui
nous rejoint les questions seront posées
après l'intervention de monsieur voyage
bien sûr mais il n'y aura rien à
l'extérieur on va privilégier les
questions réponses ici même merci de
votre compréhension
ce week-end traumatisme
c'est bon vous êtes prêts on peut
commencer
bonjour à toutes et à tous je tiens
commun à commencer par remercier les
marseillais et les marseillais pour
leurs responsabilités depuis des
semaines alors que les contraintes
sanitaires se multiplient chacune et
chacun a su s'adapter afin de lutter
contre cette épidémie qui a contraint
notre quotidien les marseillais s'adapte
ce masque se restreignent se
contraignent à leurs côtés la ville de
marseille a su se mobiliser et répondre
concrètement aux grands défis qui s'est
présentée à nous la mobilisation de nos
élus et de toute une administration
permet de lutter contre cette épidémie
qui marquera durablement notre vie le
fameux triptyque protéger des pistes est
traité est appliqué ici depuis longtemps
marseille lutte contre le coc vide
protéger parce que ce sont 500 mille
masques réutilisable qui ont été
distribués gratuitement aux marseillais
quelle autre ville le fait protéger
parce que nous avons pris dès cet été
la décision d'acheter 20 millions de
masques chirurgicaux afin de
reconstituer notre stock stratégique
quelle autre ville
le fait protéger parce que nous avons
mobilisé la police municipale et appelé
l'état et la police nationale en soutien
pour faire respecter le port du masque
dans l'ensemble de la ville protégée
parce que le protocole sanitaire et
respecter strictement dans chacune des
470 écoles de la ville parfois
nous obligeant à les fermer pour
garantir la santé des marseillais
protéger parce que chaque jour le
bataillon des marins-pompiers réalise
des dizaines de tests surfacique ce que
peu de villes met en place actuellement
nous réalisons cette veille sanitaire
avec des équipements à la pointe de
l'innovation
quelle autre ville le fait protéger
enfin parce que nous substituant à
l'état qu'il avait pourtant annoncé la
ville distribue régulièrement aux plus
démunis des kits d'hygiène avec des
masques
nous avons également ouvert des douches
pour les sans abri et c'est notre fierté
des pistes et parce que nous réalisons
dix mille tests par jour soit 34 % de
plus qu'à paris nous le faisons dans une
action concertée et unique en france
entre lee a chu le bataillon des marins
pompiers
les laboratoires de ville et l'agencé
régionale de santé avec le bataillon des
marins pompiers
nous avons été les premiers en france à
mettre en place des dispositifs de test
gratuit au plus proche de la population
notamment pour ceux dans l'accès aux
soins est le plus difficile
cette action fait de notre ville le
territoire le plus testé en france
dépister parce que nous contrôlons
chaque jour les eaux usées afin
d'évaluer la situation du coc vide dans
notre ville nous sommes la seule ville à
mettre en place ce système est
d'ailleurs la contamination des eaux
usées est en baisse régulière
cette semaine nous avons également mis
en place une surveillance accrue pour
nos ehpad et enfin traiter et soigner et
je veux insister sur ce point parce que
depuis le début de la crise
ceux qui soignent le font avec courage
ils le font dans des conditions
difficiles dans des hôpitaux que l'état
à laisser se détériorer
ils le font à flux tendu et ils sont
fatigués fatiguée parce qu'ils attendent
de l'état autre chose que des
déclarations de leur ministre ils
attendent une aide
réelle concrète des moyens pour
continuer de soigner les malades du cobp
ide et les autres parce que derrière les
polémiques que tentent d'alimenter
monsieur véran il y à cette réalité une
réalité que je lui ai rappelé la semaine
dernière celle des services hospitaliers
abandonnés par l'état d'une ap hm qui
souffrent de ne pas avoir les moyens
pour réaliser ses missions
toutes ces actions menées avec
volontarisme par l'amérique ses services
tous les partenaires locaux ont commencé
à porter leurs fruits
notre territoire 1ère 0 inférieur à 1
soit le taux de contamination le plus
bas de france avec un 0 à 0 89 c'est le
signe que la situation peut s'améliorer
dans les jours à venir
monsieur véran l'a reconnu lui-même dans
sa conférence de presse les derniers
chiffres officiels du ministère de la
santé indique que le pic de cette phase
de l'épidémie a été atteint dans la
semaine du 3 au 9 septembre
depuis le taux de positivité ne fait que
reculer
il est de 8,2 pour cent ici contre 10% à
paris selon santé publique france ces
premiers résultats encourageants aurait
mérité d'être saluée par le ministre de
la santé et par l'ensemble du
gouvernement
pourtant malgré l'évidence malgré les
chiffres malgré les efforts une nouvelle
fois notre territoire est aujourd'hui
sanctionner unis montré du doigt alors
vous comprendrez que nous sommes
aujourd'hui dans l'incompréhension dans
l'incompréhension et dans la colère
comme l'a dit michel rubio là parce que
notre ville vient d'être mise en quasi
confinement sans que personne n'ait été
concertés
je n'ai été prévenu par le préfet qu'une
heure avant le début de la conférence de
presse de monsieur vers ans sans que le
ministre ne prenne la peine d'appeler la
mer ou de me téléphoner
j'ai moi même dû contacter le ministre
pour lui demander une explication et
tenter d'ouvrir une concertation
cette concertation nous l'avions
pourtant voulue au niveau local avec le
préfet la rs les collectivités locales
jamais jamais de telles mesures
n'avaient été évoqué même au moment de
la remontée du virus au mois d'août se
voir imposer de nouvelles mesures sans
aucune concertation est vécue par
marseille comme un affront il en va du
respect de la deuxième ville de france
ce n'est pas simplement une question
protocolaires
quand je parle de la ville je pense
d'abord aux milliers de marseillais qui
ont appris avec surprise qu'il se
retrouvait dans une robe dans une zone
rouge écarlate nouvelles couleurs
inventé pour marseille et pour la
guadeloupe avec des restrictions
incroyable des décisions qui ont plongé
dans la stupeur
le monde économique local mais plus
encore toutes celles et tous ceux qui
continuent à aller travailler à se
déplacer à vivre ce choix il se fait au
détriment des marseillais et des
marseillais qui ces dernières semaines
ont démontré leur citoyenneté et leur
capacité à respecter les gestes barrière
je pense ce matin particulièrement aux
restaurateurs et aux commerçants qui
vivent une période noire puisqu'ils sont
souvent les premières victimes des
décisions changeantes de ce gouvernement
ce n'est pas rien ce sont des milliers
d'emplois dans la ville et avec eux une
grande part de la vie sociale
une grande part de la vie de marseille
mais je pense aussi à ceux qui prennent
les transports à ceux qui continuent de
travailler à ce qu'ils entreprennent ce
qui anime la vie culturelle ceux qui
essaient de maintenir une
normal dans un moment qui ne l'est pas
et qui sont totalement perdus depuis
hier parce qu'il ne s'attendait
absolument pas à cette décision leur
santé est notre priorité et c'est pour
cela que je n'accepte pas que nous
n'acceptons pas avec madame la maire
d'être l'outil d'une politique spectacle
et d'annonce d'un ministre qui peine à
gérer ses échecs des masques aux écoles
en passant par les tests et que dire de
ces contradictions quand on assouplit un
jour les règles sanitaires dans les
écoles et qu'on l'ait durci dans les
cafés le lendemain
marseille ne peut pas être utilisé pour
des démonstrations de force
les déclarations d'hier soir sont
irrationnels et je veux qu'on retrouve
de la sérénité dans ce moment une
sérénité scientifique qui s'appuie sur
des chiffres concrets pas sur un
ressenti pas sur une interprétation pas
sur des opérations de communication
ministérielle marseille mérite mieux que
des coups de boutoir ou de servir
d'exemple nous demandons aux ministres
de revoir sa politique
au regard de ces données nous lui
demandons de discuter avec les acteurs
locaux pour trouver des mesures adaptées
comme il le déclare si bien de prendre
la peine de nous appeler avant de faire
des annonces à la télévision ce serait
sans doute le minimum minimorum pour une
ville qui se mobilisent entièrement est
souvent seule
pour éviter que la situation ne dégénère
et je vais le demander clairement au
premier ministre nous voulons que l'état
révise ses annonces au regard des
chiffres du ministère de la santé et
qu'il le fasse dans la transparence
l'épidémie décroît depuis quelques jours
monsieur véran l'a reconnu lui-même
laissons à cette inflexion le temps de
se confirmer
nous n'avons pas peur des décisions
fortes
mais il faut qu'elle soit juste il faut
qu'elles soient objectives
il en va de la crédibilité de l'action
publique avec madame la maire je demande
au gouvernement dix jours avant la mise
en place de nouvelles mesures si à la
fin de la semaine prochaine les
indicateurs repartent à la hausse
nous serons prêts à prendre les
décisions qui s'imposent et qui seront
alors comprise par tout le monde
nous convoquerons la cellule de suivi de
l'accord vide chaque jour pour suivre la
situation au plus près mais d'ici là il
faut tu 1ér hâtivement que les mesures
de l'état soient gelés il est de notre
responsabilité de sortir collectivement
de cette situation ubuesque est
dramatique pour le quotidien et l'avenir
des marseillais et des marseillais cet
après midi je me rendrai à la préfecture
comme la ville le fait chaque semaine
pour gérer la crise du coc vide
je vais le faire avec une demande claire
simple
marseille deuxième ville de france doit
être entendue et respectée
les marseillais et les marseillais le
mérite
je vous remercie merci merci monsieur le
premier adjoint on va prendre quelques
questions s'il vous plaît soyez gentil
pour rester à vos places pour respecter
la distanciation et vous présenter de
façon à ce que monsieur le maire puisse
vous répondre
bonjour stéphanie à amiens pour
libération bonjour est ce que vous
pouvez revenir sur la séquence
hier justement sur cette question du
manque de concertation le ministre de la
santé dit qu'il a discuté avec vous et
avec le président de région et comment
est ce que concrètement ça s'est passé
hier j'ai reçu un coup de téléphone vers
17h30 du préfet avec le préfet il n'y a
pas de sujet c'est un préfet qui
concerte c'est un préfet qui discute on
a d'ailleurs entamé un vrai dialogue
avec la préfecture depuis son arrivée il
est dans l' écoute
il est dans les changes mais il m'a
appris que le conseil de défense avait
pris la décision le matin même de faire
passer marseille en rouge écarlate je
lui ai demandé ce à quoi ça
correspondait il m'a expliqué que
marseille est très certainement la
guadeloupe il n'a pas voulu me donner
d'autres informations en tout cas que
marseille seul territoire métropolitain
serait placée en rouge écarlate et que
les rp fermerait que les bars et que les
restaurants fermerait pour une durée de
15 jours que les gymnases fermerait que
les salles de sport fermerait évidemment
je lui ai fait part de mon étonnement en
lui disant que j'aurais aimé bien
évidemment que le ministres discutent
avec nous et que j'aurais aimé ne pas
apprendre comme ça une décision aussi
lourde de conséquences descendu de paris
comme une pierre tombe d'un pont
le préfet a écouté républicainement ce
que j'avais à lui dire et ça s'est
arrêté là
vers 18h30 sentant que la conférence de
presse du ministre allait arriver j'ai
pris moi même les devants en l'appelant
il m'a rappelée puisque je n'ai pas
réussi à le joindre et il m'a expliqué
ce que m'avait dit le ministre je lui ai
indiqué que je n'acceptais pas que nous
n'acceptions pas ces mesures là qu'elle
ne pouvait pas être dans ce moment
particulier au moment où la ville de
marseille a fait des efforts unique et
je vous rappelle qu'on a très tôt pris
les devants parce qu'avec le bataillon
des marins pompiers on a mis en place
justement des tests quotidiens sur les
eaux usées qui nous ont permis dès le
mois de juillet de sentir la remontée
épidémique puisqu'on a trouvé
fréquemment tous les jours et en nombre
conséquent augmentant chaque jour des
traces de covin c'est ce qui nous a
permis de prendre des décisions fortes
tout de suite
l'achat des 20 millions de masques la
reconstitution du stock stratégique
la distribution gratuite sans condition
à l'ensemble des marseillais et des
marseillais qui en faisait la demande de
masques
ce qui nous a permis de décider de faire
tester de manière massive
inconditionnels tout les marseillais
tous les marseillais qui en faisait la
demande de monter des barnums dans
chaque arrondissement avec le bataillon
des marins-pompiers et donc d'être à la
pointe de faire de la pédagogie
justement c'est ce qui nous a permis
d'expliquer aux marseillais et aux
marseillais qu'on avait une remontée
épidémique à ce moment là c'est pour ça
que les décisions qu'on a prises ont été
très fortes
on suit à la ville de marseille et c'est
peut-être une des seules villes de
france qui le fait de manière aussi
forte dans les écoles pierre huguet
monsieur l'adjoint et vous avez là
dessus une ligne de conduite exemplaire
qui aurait dû être d'ailleurs salué par
le ministre de l'éducation nationale on
a pris des décisions fortes
on teste dès qu'on a un cas de co vide
l'école en y faisant des tests
surfacique le bataillon des marins
pompiers s'y rendant leur on désinfecte
on sort les personnels qui sont
contaminés on fait notre possible en
remplaçant le plus possible les
personnels de la ville de marseille dans
qu'on a pris la mesure de cette réalité
là et quand le gouvernement a lui aussi
senti que ça remonte et on a accompagné
les décisions du gouvernement
pas de gaieté de coeur on n'est pas
content de devoir porter le masque c'est
contraignant ça comptera nos libertés
mais c'est ainsi qu'on se protège et on
a aucun sujet vis-à-vis de ça bien au
contraire la maire de marseille est
médecin
nous avons aujourd'hui avec cette
majorité mais plus largement parce que
ce n'est pas qu'une question politique
la conscience aiguë que ce moment de
crise particulier il doit être
surmontées et qu'il faut faire des
efforts et c'est le rôle d'une
municipalité de faire des efforts et
c'est pour ça qu'on a accompagné les
mesures qui nous était proposé
on n'a pas fait de gaieté de coeur je
vous le répète mais on l'a fait et c'est
pour ça qu'on a été la seule
collectivité la semaine dernière à se
tenir aux côtés de l'état du préfet de
région du directeur général de la rs du
directeur général de l'assistance
publique des hôpitaux de marseille et du
préfet de police pour réaffirmer notre
volonté de lutter efficacement ensemble
quelles que soient les divergences que
nous puissions avoir contre le coc vite
mais là mais la madame à rognan
cette décision cette méthode au moment
tous ces efforts parce que c'est là
dessus que je veux insister ont payé au
moment où on sent justement que le pic
est derrière nous que nous sommes dans
le plateau il ya même une inflexion des
chiffres que nous avons eus 0 le plus
bas du pays que nous avons un taux de
contamination plus faibles une dizaine
de départements français à ce moment-là
choisir marseille comme un exemple en
faire un bouc émissaire alors que
marseille a assumé seul avec les autres
collectivités la charge et la difficulté
de devoir faire face à cette épidémie
alors que marseille a organisé seuls les
tests la distribution de masques le
travail au quotidien dans les écoles ça
n'était pas acceptable ça n'était pas
acceptable de ne pas avoir parlé au
monde économique
ce n'était pas acceptable de ne pas
avoir consulté concertée discuter nous
sommes la deuxième ville du pays
nous ne sommes pas un exemple à montrer
du doigt et nous ne l'acceptons pas
notre question s'il vous plaît
bonjour présentez-vous juste pour être
sûr à partir de coin la mesure entre en
vigueur
d'abord et à quelle sanction des
contrevenants mais d'abord apparemment
le le ministre a indiqué que ce serait
ça me dit lundi j'ai pas compris
exactement puisqu'il a annoncé beaucoup
de choses en même temps et qu'il a
[Musique]
multiplié les annonces hier soir il
semblerait que cette fois samedi cet
après midi nous irons rencontrer le
préfet justement sur la question du coc
vide mais moi je ne perds pas espoir de
ramener le gouvernement français à la
raison on ne peut pas faire d'un des
territoires qui justement a été le plus
impacté par l'épidémie mais qui est
certainement le territoire qui a réagi
avec le plus de vigueur avec le plus de
bienveillance avec la conscience aiguë
qu'il avait une responsabilité on ne
peut pas faire de ce territoire un
territoire
montrée du doigt on ne peut pas le faire
passer en rouge écarlate de cette
manière là donc je ne perds pas espoir
et nous ne perdons pas espoir de
d'entamer une discussion normale avec
les autorités de ce pays et de leur dire
gelé cette décision entendez nous vous
laissons la possibilité aux
scientifiques de consolider ces chiffres
on a des chiffres qui nous in qui nous
montre depuis quatre à cinq jours plus
qu stack plus qu'une stagnation mais une
inflexion laissant à ces chiffres parce
que c'est trop tôt pour crier victoire
loin de là et on continuera d'ailleurs à
être extrêmement attentifs dans la
manière dont on va distribuer les
masques dont on va continuer le combat
contre le provident mais laissant la
possibilité et ses dix jours nécessaires
puisque le ministre lui même nous dit il
faut quinze jours pour avoir une vision
claire d'une situation sanitaire
laissons-nous dix jours ci au bout de
ces dix jours l'épidémie reprend
on est prêt à assumer des mesures fortes
parce que tout le monde l'ait comprendra
6 au bout de dix jours les chiffres nous
montrent que le virus a explosé que la
situation est catastrophique dangereuse
alors on acceptera un confinement qui ne
dit pas son nom
parce qu'on aura été consultés parce
qu'on aura discuté mais si au bout de
dix jours les chiffres confirment ce qui
est en train de se passer à quoi aura
servi à quoi auront servi ces mesures a
donné une victoire politique au ministre
en disant vous avez vu je vous l'avais
bien dit c'est pas compliqué on sait
qu'ici ça marche on sait qu'ici c'est
possible je ne veux pas que nous savions
d'exemple voilà je vous remercie encore
une question bonjour françois cau de la
provence certains restaurateurs et
cafetiers envisage d'ouvrir quand même
les interdictions eux
si jamais votre proposition n'aboutit
pas le gel les encourage françois
tonneau vous voyez bien que c'est une
décision qui n'est pas comprise vous
voyez bien qu'au moment où on a déjà
imposé des restrictions aux cafetiers
mais des restrictions qu'ils ont compris
qu'ils ont été difficiles il sortait
d'une période qui a été dramatique pour
l'économie de leur entreprise à ce
moment là ils prennent hier soir une
douche froide
ils sont laminés par ce que dit le
ministre sans qu'à aucun moment ils
étaient déconcertés sans qu'ils aient
plus eux-mêmes travailler à des mesures
peut-être plus restrictives ce quasi
confinement est dur à encaisser mais
pour tout vous dire moi je ne crois pas
que le gouvernement fasse la sourde
oreille
moi je ne crois pas que le gouvernement
s'entête et s'enferre dans l'erreur
qu'il est en train de commettre
laissons du temps on ne dévitalise pas
la deuxième ville de france comme ça
voilà je vous remercie
alors si vous voulez faire quelques
images tv ou quelques morceaux de son